Hello, good morning to all of you, am I audible clearly?
So, today we are going to start about the supervised learning, so basically last class
already we have got the very good exposure in terms of the theoretical development.
So, Dr. Avigran Chakravarti has spoken about the different techniques, tools and techniques
related to supervised learning for example, he has already spoken about the support vector
machine KNN and Nape-based classifier, so already you got those idea that how to implement
them and how to explore them on those angles, now this particular session will be basically
based on the hands-on experience, so already Mr. Shumon Kumar Berra beautifully has taken
your python session, so myself I have a PhD research scholar from Center for Computational
Data Sciences of IIT Kharagpur, so I will also cover up the basic aspects of this supervised
machine learning, so there you will learn how to explore the python or pythonic platforms
in Google Colab to execute certain problems related to machine learning using the tools
like support vector machine, KNN as well as Nape-based classifier, so all of you are quite
accustomed with the IIT data set I believe, I will also give you some idea, so we will
continue with the same type of the data set, so that all of you can align yourself where
Shumon has left during his last hands-on session, so let us start, so those who are new to Google
Colab, I believe that all of you got some exposure for the classes of the March, February 15
and February 22 about the Google Colab during the hands-on session of Shumon, but I am also
giving you some idea that how to explore, use it, so those who remember it fine directly
open it, those who still feeling some confusion just follow my instruction, so in Google simply
type Google Colab and then you open it up, so for example if I open up like the Colab
notebook, so you can just click on it, so basically what you can do, you can go to the
file section and then click on the new notebook in drive, so it will open up in new window,
so this is my original notebook and from this particular notebook, I will use it and will
show you that how to run certain chunk of code in Colab cells, so this is for example
I can put some name, this is a new notebook, I can put some name like for example demo1,
you can give something like that, like demo1 or demo ml, something like that you can put
some name there, so this particular segment as you can see plus code plus text, these
two options are given, so plus text option you can use if you want to put some text there,
like for example if I want to write SVM just for example, so I can keep it there, for example
as you can see it is appearing here, so this is how text can be written or like for example
you want to bold it, so that is also doable, so you can select it, you can click on plus
b that stands for bold and you can make it bold, so as you can see it has appeared in
bold, so in this way whenever you are coming again you see a plus code plus text buttons
are given there, so you can click on plus code and you can run your portion, you can
write the code and then run this particular portion with the help of clicking on this
run cell button, this portion is called the run cell, so it will show you the execution
time, while running it not only it will, if you can run successfully the green tick button
will appear and it will show some time like 2 second, 1 second in this way, so this is
the original notebook, so those who are new to it I will always request all of you to
type it, I will wait for all of you, nothing to worry about it, so I will give you some
time to execute the code and you just try to type it or those who have access, those
who got the link of my GitHub account, they can directly access the code from my GitHub.
So this is basically a repository for those who are new to it for them I am showing, this
is the basically the repository as you can see, so those who directly got it fine, those
who do not got it just I am just showing you, you can directly even access to the Google
by Google search, so suppose I am over the GitHub if you type, you can directly get it
from here also, so I am just showing those who got the link fine, those who are still
in confusion for them I am just showing it, so if you go to the repository, so repository
ml using python is at the top, so you go to that repository and then this one, SVM different
kernels just above the simple linear regression and below the random search, just click on
it and directly you can open and you can also access the code from there, so this is the
code you can download also by clicking this particular button download raw file, you can
download the notebook.
So these are the way you can directly download the codes from my GitHub fine and then let
us start executing one by one and another interesting file you can open up if you wish,
so this particular file is basically the explanation of the code which I am going to use now.
So I have shared this notebook and this particular PDF file to all of you, so it is available
in the TCS and portal, so you can access it and you can also download apart from that
you can also download by clicking on this download raw file.
So here I have added the codes and relevant other relevant explanations for supervised
learning part one, so those who are new to it nothing to worry about it, I have given
all the relevant information and during the hands on session I request all of you kindly
type it and those who already know this particular portion please consider this as a good practice
or good revision, so that those who are new they can get some chances to explore it because
those who are new for them they need some time to type, they need some time to grab the concept.
So because of that I request those who are already well known to this or familiar to
this kindly have their patience and consider this as a good practice so that others can
also get some scope to learn it.
So let us make the session ubiquitous for all, so let us start.
So now for example at first we are importing the necessary Python packages, so from your
basics from your basic knowledge of Python already you have got idea that we need to
import certain packages whenever we start exploring.
So for example import numpy as NP, so what it will do it will give you some opportunity
to explore the array related operations in Python or Python platforms.
So for example in Colab you can run the course related to Python and Python platforms like
TensorFlow, Keras, PyTorch etc. then for example we can import pandas spd.
So it will give you all data frame related operations, manipulations you can do here.
Then import matplotlib.pyplotsplt, so what does it do?
It will basically help the Python platforms to act like matlab like environment, so that
you can easily draw the plots and all those things.
For Seaborn as SNS, so during the confusion matrix when you will form the confusion matrix
you will see the use of Seaborn, if you do not use you will not get the extra opportunity
of exploring the color collects, matplotlib will give you the idea of the opportunity
to plots the figures, but Seaborn gives you the additional color pledges by operating
over matplotlib to generate the very beautiful colorful plots.
For example in today's session during drawing the confusion matrix you will learn about it
and then from sklearn.metric will import accuracy score, confusion matrix as well as the classification
report.
So this particular segment those who are new to it nothing to worry about it, you will
get the, when you will study you will get the recorded version of this particular session
and not only that for learning purpose I have added this portion.
So here you see the explanation of NumPy which I have explained now, pandas, scikit-learn,
matplotlib as well as pyplot and then the Seaborn till now whatever I have explained
everything is present there.
So for your assistance purpose sometime I will switch to this particular window as well
so that I can show you that all the relevant information is present in this particular
PDF file which is loaded in my Github.
So that you can easily get the access and understand the concept.
So now let us let me show you the execution.
So let me go back to the demo window and let us click on the run cell button.
So it will execute and when the execution is done successfully a green thing will appear
along with the execution time.
So it is now what is the time, it is now 9.11.
So please finish this simple step by 9.13.
So two more minutes will be good enough to finish it up.
So let us go back to the demo window.
So already you can see this green tick has appeared and two second execution time has
been shown as two seconds.
It may shown as zero second, one second so in this way you will see it.
So please explore this and once you are done then we shall proceed to the next step.
So I encourage all of you please type it.
You will already have the access of the codes and all those things but however I will suggest
that those who are new to it will get lot of confidence when you type it.
So please type it.
So I shall wait for another more minute and then we shall move to the next step of downloading
the iris data set.
So through this particular step in the next step you will learn about how to access the
online data set directly from the web link.
This is an art.
So there are many options like you can load the external data set, you can directly access
the data set from the web link.
So this particular case or today's session you will learn how to access the web link
and then explore and process the data.
So as you can see in this notebook also like for the first step at first we are importing
the necessary Python packages or for example in the next step when we are going to explore
the let us download the iris data set from its web link as follows.
So all the necessary text has been added there so that you can easily smoothly learn about
the steps.
In the next step there is one online link is available so I request you to post the link
in the comment box section because it will be difficult for them to type especially those
who are new they may make mistake.
So that is why to avoid the mistake it will be better if we can put the link only put
the link there.
So once you type in the next step whenever you are typing just keep path equals to and
then copy the link given in the comment section.
So do not forget to keep the double code and then put it put the link there.
So has it been given fine so already moderator has given it there.
So from our side moderator is Mr. Devjit Bishas so he will try to give you all kind of support.
So let us download the iris data set from its web link this is our next step.
So already all of you got the link in the comment box section please look into the comment
box section.
So path equals to you just type it path equals to and then you can put it there and those
who are directly accessing from GitHub they can directly get it.
So then just run this particular portion so as you can see if I go to the demo window
it has run smoothly and you can see this printing has appeared and the time is also given the
0 second.
So I shall wait for 1 minute and then we shall move ahead.
So it is now 9.16 so I will wait for 9.17 so that everyone get the opportunity to explore
this particular code and then what we will do we shall start the next portion to assign
the column names to the data set.
In the next portion we shall assign the column names to the data set.
So please complete this step and then we shall move to the next portion.
Well I shall wait for few more seconds before we go to the next step I hope that most of
you already have completed it and those who are doing it please finish it.
Well so let us go to the next step now it is time to move forward and let us see the
next step.
Now what we will do we will assign the column names to the data set as follows.
So already path is given there web link has been assigned to the path and then what we
will do in the next section header names equals to sepal length sepal width petal length petal
width and class.
So there are 5 columns in the iris data set 150 rows and 5 columns that we will see whenever
we are going to process a new data set we will see the overall structure of the data
to understand number of rows columns present in the data, what are the features present
in the data.
So here sepal length sepal width petal length petal width these are basically the features
which are present in the data and class is basically the labeling whether it is iris
setosa iris virginica or iris versicolor.
So if you check this particular description present in the data set so you can see for
your assistant purpose also added the GitHub link to go to that particular notebook and
the data set description if you see what I have written there that this particular data
set was used in a classic paper by R.A. Fisher in 1936.
And this is also available in the UCI machine learning repository actually from that particular
web link you have access the data in the present session.
And then like I mentioned that there will be total 150 samples and within this 150 samples
each category is present as 50 samples like for example iris setosa or iris versicolor
or iris virginica and python is a zero indexing language.
So that is why the index value will range from 0 to 149 simple calculation.
So 0 to 149 will be for values for the iris setosa sequentially it will go.
So what will happen if we go by sequentially so 0 to 149 will be iris setosa 50 to 99 index
values will be iris versicolor and 100 to 149 will be iris virginica.
But still I have mentioned those things very clearly so that those who are new they can
easily learn from it.
It will be easier to follow if certain reference text is there in front of you.
So in this way you can do it.
So let us now explore the header names.
So now let us proceed.
So as we see as we are proceeding to the demo window so again two options will appear plus
text plus code.
So all of you know what you have to do you have to click on the plus code button and
then you can put it there and run by clicking on the run button.
So you can see easily it has run and the execution time is 0 second.
So I request all of you it is now 920 by 922 complete this step.
So I am giving you some time and do it very carefully because those who are new they will
take some time for them to type so please do not get fear.
The more you will type the more you will practice you will gain the confidence.
So this is the policy.
In programming there is no shortcut you have to practice to master on it.
So nowadays you have lot of options in your hand to get the reference code from GitHub
source code from GitHub also you have the options like chat GPT to correct your codes
but you should have the coding intuition within you.
So that you can understand whatever the code you are accessing whether it will work for
it or not or what are the changes you need to do to run the code smoothly.
So that type of the insight will only grow when you practice it understand the logic
of the code and you are practicing it.
So there is no shortcut in it.
So hard work practice and applying your common sense your intuition that will help you to
gain the success.
So I am requesting all of you kindly type it.
I hope most of you already have completed it and those who are doing it please finish
it but while typing type carefully see the screen carefully and do it or already those
who are accessing directly my GitHub so they can easily see the reference code.
So please do it carefully while typing.
So it is already 9.23 so I shall wait for few more seconds and then move to the next
step.
So let us move to the next step.
So now what we will do this is another interesting way like I told you that in pandas basically
what we will do it helps us to access the data frame and other manipulating operations.
So what you can do you can type already we have load the pandas as PD if you remember
to go to the top you see import pandas as PD.
So that is why we are using PD.
So data equals to PD dot read underscore CSV.
So first argument section what will be within the function path because you have to show
the data path it is given there and names equals to header names and then you click
on data write data dot shape.
So what you will get you will get the entire data shape what are the number of rows what
are the number of columns will be there it will be there.
So this is the very simple step which you can explore.
So again all of you know what you have to do you have to click on plus code button and
then you just put the code there or type it and then you get the result.
As you can see again the green tick has appeared and execution time is 0 second and as you
can see there are 150 rows and 5 columns like I mentioned during the data set description.
Whenever you do any analysis with a new data set always try to see the data what is the
data structure look like what is the data set description how it has been captured.
So for example whenever we are downloading data set from some web link or loading the
excel file to analyze the data these all data sets are the secondary data set because you
have not yourself have not got the data set through certain experiments or through survey
it is already present there you are accessing it sometimes people also buy data set from
others.
So these all are the secondary data set so then what is primary data set primary data
set is basically when through certain experiment you are collecting data in your lab you are
doing some experiments and you are collecting data or through some IOT setup or internet
of thing setup you are collecting some real time data or it can be some survey data as
well in certain area you are doing survey and collecting data.
So these are the good examples of the primary data.
So that is why when you do the analysis you always have to remember that how the data
has been collected so that during the preprocessing step you can understand that if there are certain
lacuna's present within the data which you can overcome during the preprocessing.
So there can be some sort of the noise may present in the data or there are some sort
of the you may have to do the background extraction in the data.
So those things are possible when you understand entirely about the data especially for the
secondary data in primary data yourself is collecting it.
So you have certain idea that what are the instruments or the tools techniques you have
used to collect the data but for the secondary data set data set description is very important
and that is why you may see in during accessing the data from Kaggle or GitHub the scholar
person always put some data set description.
So that is why I am telling that to follow the data set description is very important.
So today's class is for the new learners for the beginners who are starting their journey
in machine learning.
So we are going through this type of the example but whenever you will gradually whenever you
will get some experiences yourself will be able to understand why I am mentioning that
and why understanding the data set is important.
So it is now 9.27 so please complete this step within next 2 minutes 9.29.
Thank you.
.
So while typing be careful so that there should not be any error so make sure you are doing
it carefully.
So I shall wait for few more seconds and then move to the next step.
So I believe most of you already have completed it and those who are doing it please finish
.
So let us move to the next step.
Now let us observe the data.
So in Python or any programming languages you always have certain option because you see
to observe lengthy data is very difficult as if it is data set is long.
So better to follow first few observations or last few observations while observing the
data in data science domain there are two popular programming languages.
One is R another one is Python.
In R and Python in both the cases you have that type of the opportunity to observe first
few rows of the data set or last few rows of the data set in R programming head tell function
options are there along with the data.
In Python also analogously you have that option.
In Python the interestingly if we put data dot head operation so you will be able to
see first few first five rows.
As I mentioned that Python is a zero indexing language so it will always start from zero.
So already you know that there are 150 rows.
So when you do the data dot head operation it will give so you first five rows so that
means the index value will be 0 to 4 what you can observe in the left hand side 0, 1,
2, 3, 4.
Already I told you that there are features like sepal length, sepal width, petal length,
petal width and the class column you have the levellings of the three species.
So from 0 to 49 it is iris setosa, sequentially it is there, then 52, 99 iris virginica,
100 to 149 iris versicolor so those who forget for them I am just showing this line you see.
I already have mentioned it there 0 to 49 for the iris setosa, 0 iris versicolor 52,
99 iris virginica, 100 to 149.
So obviously if you are seeing first five observations so definitely all of them will
be iris setosa.
It is quite apparent from our common sense.
So let us implement this portion.
So it is a very small chunk of code, you will require only a few seconds to run it but still
that is the beginner session so I will wait for a minute.
So it is now 931 please finish this by 932.
So I believe all of you can complete it by 932 so it is just a small chunk of code just
execute it and check the data overall data how the data look like.
So let us move to the next step.
Now we will see the very basic step of data preprocessing, how to do the data preprocessing.
Let us see like I told you in any data say data preprocessing is the utmost important
step.
So this purpose what we will do we will take data dot iloc, iloc stands for the integer
location to accessing the index values.
So this particular explanation is also added there.
If you want to check for them I am just showing what I mentioned now you see I have highlighted
what is iloc function.
So this is already mentioned.
Now what we will do data dot iloc colon comma so left hand side of the comma while accessing
the index colon means you are taking all the rows in consideration but in column section
colon minus one dot values because whenever you are forming the predictor variables to
avoid the class column because this is the target variable class column is the target
variable we will not consider it.
So for that purpose colon minus one and then to define the target variable why data dot
iloc colon four dot values why colon in the left hand side of the comma I already told
you are taking all the rows but in right hand side four means this is the fourth index value
because column wise it is a zero indexing language Python I already told you.
So it will start from zero zero one two three four so class is basically the fourth index
so because of that it is already four.
So data y equals to data dot iloc colon comma four dot values that is why it is the y is
the target variable and x is your predictor variable.
So that you have to define what is your predictor variable what is your target variable then
only you can proceed so that is how you define x and y.
So now it is nine thirty four so finish this simple step by nine thirty six.
So it has run successfully and you can see the execution time zero second.
So finish this step and then we shall move to the next part.
Let me go to the original notebook and do it.
In the next step we will do the ten test split.
So for example in this data set we will take the seventy percent for the training thirty
percent for the testing.
In your case in generally the machine learning conventions as per the machine learning operations
those who are the practitioner as per their recommendations seventy percent in general
we keep for the training thirty percent for the testing or for example you may also keep
eighty percent for the training and twenty percent for the testing.
So whatever you may do you have to mention in the code that we will see very soon first
you finish the step and then we will see that operations.
How we are defining whether to take twenty percent or thirty percent of the test data.
So that we will see.
So I shall wait for another more minute and then move to the next step.
So I request all of you to finish it those who already have done it fine those who are
still doing it I will finish it.
Thank you.
Well so let us move to the next step I believe all of you have been able to finish the step.
Now like I mentioned that in this step I also added the explanation there if you can see
that we are dividing the data into train and test split where seventy percent we are considering
of the entire data set for the training and thirty percent for the testing.
So as this is there are data size is 150 150 rows.
So by our mental calculation if you calculate in mind thirty percent of 150 will be 45.
So 45 samples will be for test data size and 105 remaining 105 will be for your training.
So from a scale on okay this is I already mentioned that cycle learn is used for the
machine learning related operations to provide the support related to machine learning okay.
So from a scale on dot model underscore selection we shall import the train test split.
So that we can do this ten test split operation and then we will assign the ten test split
function over x and y.
X is your target variable y is your predicted variable and then test size.
So as we are taking thirty percent.
So that is why we have mentioned that test size is 0.30.
If you have taken that twenty percent or twenty five percent it would have been 0.20 or 0.25
respectively.
So accordingly the size you are choosing you define it there okay and then it will be stored
under the X test X train X test Y train Y test okay and their explanations also added
in the it is already present in the data set okay.
So that you can check in this particular file okay so just a second.
Let me just put this execution here.
So all of you know what will be the next step it will be the plus code button you just put
it there and then you click on the run cell button and it has done successfully.
So you can see the green tick has appeared and it is showing the execution time at 0
second okay.
So it is now nine thirty eight so finish this step within next two minutes by nine forty
so that we can move to the next execution okay.
So I believe all of you are doing it carefully okay.
So those who are new to this I am I again repeat that please type it I am giving you
adequate time to execute it so please type it.
So I shall wait for few more seconds and then move to the next step those who are new to
it please finish it up I am going back to the original notebook window.
So in the next step we shall do the data scaling okay.
So I am going to do the data scaling okay.
So let us move to the next step.
So now what we will do?
We will do the data scaling so that means the normalization operation okay.
So you may have one data set of size for example 0 to 750 or another one has the for example
250.
So how to make them comparable while executing the data analysis operation over there.
So the simple step is to put them either minus 1 to 1 range or 0 to 1 range and how to do
that the basic operation is the data normalization on data scaling okay.
So data minus min divided by standard deviation of the data is your this is how you can do
the normalization okay.
So this type of the steps has been discussed during your math classes, Maths for the IML
Dr. Budhalan Banaji has mentioned that how to do the normalization okay.
So data minus min of data divided by standard deviation of data okay.
So here how we are doing it through code that we are going to discuss now.
So from a scalar and dot prepositing import standard scalar, so standard scalar giving
you the accessibility.
This particular model is giving you the accessibility to execute the data scaling operation okay.
And then scalar equals to standard scalar and then after assigning it, scalar dot fit we
are applying over X train.
So how does it do?
What is scalar dot fit?
What is the functionality of the scalar dot fit?
Actually calculates the min and standard deviation value of the data okay.
And then whenever you are applying it over the X train and X test with the help of the
scalar dot transform that means you are doing the data minus min of data divided by standard
deviation of the data okay.
So for the train X train you can from your commonsense you can understand that train
data set minus min of train data set divided by standard deviation of the string data set.
Similarly for the scalar dot transfer X test what it will happen?
X test data set minus min of X test divided by standard deviation of X train data set.
So this is how it happens for data scaling in python or pythonic platforms okay.
So let us implement it now.
So here you see plus code plus text pattern is there, so click on the plus code and let
us put it there and click on the run cell button to execute the entire operation.
So you see the green tick has appeared and the execution time is shown as 0 second okay.
So it is 9.43, so please finish this step by 9.45, so that we can move to the next step.
Couple of minutes will be good enough to explore this one, so please do it.
Then we shall start discussing as the prepositioning will be finished.
We shall start with the first supervised learning classifier and that would be Nape based classifier
okay.
So please finish this up.
Okay, so I shall wait for another more minute before we can proceed to the next step.
I believe those who are typing they are gradually getting confidence.
The more the hands-on session will proceed you will gain the confidence gradually on
the subject okay.
So in the beginning we have given some theory classes just to build your foundations that
is it.
So from today's class onwards you will have the hands-on session regularly okay.
Already Sumonbeta has set up may give you some idea or the set up the background for
using pythons and now for example the other PhD research scholar like me and the other
scholars will give you the idea on the journey of the machine learning to how to explore
the course in the machine learning domain deep learning as well as NLP.
So there are many interesting sessions you will also learn large language model or LLMs
okay.
So you will see a lot of interesting examples in upcoming sessions.
So stay tuned with us okay.
So let us start this particular portion.
Now here we will use the nav best so in the last session in the last theory class of past
March Dr. Obigay and Chakraborty already has given you the idea what is nav best algorithm
and this is completely based on the best theorem all of you know okay.
So best theorem is also relying on the conditional probability okay there will be certain conditions
and accordingly you have to proceed prior probability information will be there and
you have to calculate the posterior probability.
So anyway so basically here in terms of the coding when we will explore we are going to
explore a particular type of the nav best that is the Gaussian nav best which is the
simplest and the very effective for the small data set.
So as you see the data there are one two rows so it is a small data size okay.
So that is why Gaussian nav best is the optimal option to go ahead with it because it will
consider it will execute the nav best operation by considering the entire data set as a Gaussian
distribution or normal distribution okay.
So from a scalar dot nav best we shall import the Gaussian NB and classifier will be assigned
as the Gaussian NB and then what we will do we will use the classifier dot fit function
over X train and Y train okay and we will see what happens.
So let me put it in the demo window as well okay and although I request all of you to
complete this step it is now 946 so finish this step by 948 okay 2 more minutes will
be good enough to finish this up.
So as you can see this green tick has appeared and the execution time is 0 second okay.
So how fast it is executing all of you can understand okay.
So let me go back to the original notebook and wait for all of you.
So before we go to the calculations of the accuracy okay on the training and test data
test so first of all let us finish this up okay.
So let us go back to the original notebook and see how it is going to be done okay.
I will wait for few more seconds before going to the next step so I believe all of you are
doing it those who have completed it fine those who are still doing it please finish
it. the next step is to complete the test okay.
So let us proceed.
So now let us first test the accuracy of the next best classifier over the training data
set why it is important before exploring the algorithm over the test data set to have the
idea how it is performing over the training data set just to avoid the scenarios like overfitting
okay.
So if your algorithm is working properly there should not be much difference between the
whatever that you accuracy you are getting in the training data set and then in the test
data set okay either they can be same or they can be nearby okay for example if you are
getting accuracy over the training data set 93% in this in the test data set if you are
getting 89 or 90% or better than the training data set for example 96 or 97% is absolutely
fine there is no cases of the overfitting okay but if it deviates too much like in training
data set you are getting 93 for example and the test data set you are getting something
like 50 or 60% then you have to think about okay for the effectiveness of the algorithm
and you need to do certain changes in the during the execution of the code okay.
So that it is the separate scenario but in this case let us see that how it is working
over the training data set first and then we shall move towards the test data set okay.
So now it is called classifier.predict we shall apply this particular function over
x train okay and we will assign it under vibrate and then what we will do we will calculate
the accuracy okay by applying accuracy underscore function over y train and vibrate and then
we will print it okay accordingly the way we are printing it like for example in print
function we are keeping accuracy under code and then we are printing the accuracy value.
So accuracy value is already calculated using the accuracy underscore function and then y
train vibrate.
So if you are getting something like for example here we are getting 95.24% approximately okay
as the value is 0.595238 in approximately we are taking if we are taking the 2 digit
after the decimal.
So approximately it is 95.24% approximately which is the very good accuracy for the training
data set okay.
So let us execute it in the demo window.
So like the way we are printing it will be printed okay.
So for example print accuracy colon that is why the accuracy colon has appeared and as
the accuracy value is stored under this particular variable named accuracy.
So exactly the value has been printed like the way we are printing okay.
So this is that is why I am showing this last line is very important.
Those who are new to coding for them I am saying the way you want to print it you will
type it here and accordingly it will be printed okay.
Let me check oh sorry I have missed out this line I have missed out just a second I have
missed out this line sorry for the mistake I have to first put it vibrate then we have
to go to the next step that is why it is showing that vibrate is not present.
So first we have to print the vibrate and then you run it it will run okay.
Now you are getting 0.95238 that means 95.24% okay.
So whenever you are doing it first execute the vibrate okay in this section there are
2 cells are present okay not the unicell like earlier.
So in the first cell you are getting the value of the vibrate and then you are keeping it
under the accuracy score function okay in the second argument section and then you run
it you will get okay 95.24% approximately okay.
So these 2 portion you just implement and then we shall move ahead okay.
So it is now 953 so finish this step by 955 okay then we shall move ahead for the next
portion of the execution.
So remember in this step first we are calculating vibrate and then we are calculating accuracy
score and storing it under accuracy and then we are printing the accuracy value okay.
So I repeat with the help of the classifier.predict function we are applying it over X train we
are storing it under vibrate and then what we are doing we are applying accuracy underscore
function over Y train vibrate storing it under accuracy and then we are printing the
accuracy value okay.
So I believe most of you have been able to complete it those who are doing it please finish
it soon.
So it is now 954 I shall wait for another more minute before I can proceed to the next
step so let me go with to the let me go back to the original notebook.
So like I have concluded here as you can see that for the native base classifier we are
achieving an accuracy of 95.24% approximately for training data set therefore accuracy is
good really good on the training data set.
Now we have to make the prediction which can be done in the following way.
So each step has been explained there just to guide you okay.
So in the next case what we will do we will now it is time to explore on the test data
set so we will do that.
So what we will do classifier.predict function will apply over X test and we will store it
under vibrate okay.
So I believe all of you have been able to complete the earlier steps so let us move ahead.
So first execute this and then we will print the result okay.
So while doing the printing the result in the next step we will see the use of this
C bond which I was mentioning through the head map SNS dot head map and you will see
this colorful confusion matrix plot okay.
So past finish this part and then we shall move ahead.
So click on the plus code button keep it there and then you run click on the run cell button
to run it okay.
So it is a very simple chunk of the code okay.
So it is now 9.56 so I believe one minute will be more than good enough to finish this
one okay.
So finish this up then we shall draw the confusion matrix with the help of the SNS dot head map
function.
So we have stored see we have loaded C bond as see SNS which is the abbreviated form okay.
So we will see the beauty of SNS by adding the extra color pilots to see that particular
colorful confusion matrix.
It is not only about executing the code properly or drawing the confusion matrix but to understand
them is very important.
For example if you are writing company white papers or those who are researchers writing
research papers or even if you are preparing report for your company.
So it is always important to interpret the analysis.
You may get some result through executing the code but how to represent the analysis
or to interpret it is very important.
So that is why I have tried to give you some standard reference write up so that you can
follow that write up while preparing your report through the it may be white paper company
white papers it may be research paper those who are researchers or it may be in general
report while doing analysis.
So you can easily interpret them because interpreting them properly in an understandable manner
is very much important okay.
So that is why I always mention that it is not only about executing the codes or those
things but you need to represent them in an understandable format you need to interpret
them properly so that everybody can understand it okay.
So let us move to the next part.
Now in the next step so from escalar.metric we shall import the classification report confusion
matrix and accuracy score.
We shall apply the confusion matrix over Y test and Y print and store it and result.
So sns.hitmap function under that the first argument will be the result second will be
anode equals to true.
Why it is important because you see the participating test samples will be shown in the confusion
matrix like you see 18, 11, 1 okay whether it is a correct prediction or wrong prediction
everything will be highlighted here through certain numbers as you can see in each grid
of the confusion matrix okay.
So that is why anode equals to true and then fmt equals to g is a general format okay.
So left hand side of the decimal point will be displaced okay so sorry will be displayed.
So as you can see 18, 0, 11 okay so in this way the display is done so fmt equals to
g is a general format this is this one.
X tick and Y tick level if you see setosa versicolor virginica so as you can see all
those tick levels setosa versicolor virginica has present there setosa versicolor virginica
is present there.
So anything you are mentioning in the code that should follow a certain logic okay.
So that is why I am just giving you the idea that whatever is mentioned under the sns.hitmap
function it has the meaning and the applications while drawing the figure okay.
And then plt.y level it is the prediction and you are keeping font size 13 okay.
So it is standard policy keeping font size 12 or 13 so that it can be visible to all
of you and while presenting for example you are putting this particular plot in the in
certain document it can be doc file or it can be overly poetic file it can be easily
visible while generating the pdf okay or other documents so it can be clearly visible to
the readers.
So that is why we follow certain standard font size policies okay.
Then you see for example plt.x level actual font size equals 13 so you see in the x axis
they actually is present there okay.
And then what you do you put some title so plt.title confusion matrix font size equals
to 17 so this is the confusion matrix and through plt.show it will be plot okay.
So I hope all of you got the idea and you see this is also explained here.
This particular segment if you look you will get all the idea that how the what is sns.hitmap,
what is confusion matrix, what is classifier.predict okay.
So all those concepts has been highlighted there okay under the parameters data and not
okay what I have mentioned it is exactly present there okay fmt what does g actually represents
general format which I highlighted x tick level y tick level okay.
So all those things is added in this particular reference text format which is basically through
which you can access the interpretation of the code okay.
So let us now explore it in the demo window okay so as you see the successful execution
has been done 0 second is the time and this is the confusion matrix.
Now it is time to interpret the confusion matrix so if you see this particular case
that already I told you that 30% of 152 will be 45 samples so this 45 samples will participate.
So if you see in first row it is 18 okay so as the x axis is denoting you the actual value
that means 18 has been correctly classified as satosa 18 out of 18 has been correctly
classified as satosa there is no miscalculation in first row.
In second row out of 12 versicolors 11 has been correctly classified as versicolor but
one wrongly has been classified as virginica from x axis you can check from x tick level
you can check one wrong prediction is there but in the third row 15 out of 15 virginica
has been correctly classified as virginica okay.
So I repeat 18 out of 18 satosa has been correctly classified in first row there is no wrong classification
in second row 11 out of 12 versicolor has been correctly classified as versicolor one
wrongly has been classified as virginica in third row 15 virginica has been correctly
classified as virginica there is no wrong classification okay so in all together it is 45 because
in first row 18 samples second row 11 plus 12 samples in third row 15 so it will be 45
overall okay so this is how do it so for your understanding purpose I have given I already
added the text on the story about it this all things will be accessible to all of you.
So you easily can check it out and you can understand the concept easily.
So out of 18 satosa 18 has been correctly classified as satosa out of 12 versicolor 11 has been
correctly classified as versicolor one wrongly classified as virginica out of 15 virginica
as 15 has been classified as virginica as simple as that okay.
So nothing to worry about it all those things have been given to you you just executed smoothly
okay it is now 10 3 p.m. so sorry 10 3 a.m. so please finish this step by 10 5 I think
2 minutes will be good enough to finish it okay then we shall move to the next step.
So I shall wait for another more minute I hope that all of you have been will be able
to finish this up.
Okay so let us move to the next part so now we will see the classification report okay
so in classification report how to generate it so classification underscore report we
shall apply it over the y-test y-pad and we will print the classification report okay
so followed by printing the result one as we have stored it under result one and then
you will get this type of the report this is the classification report part okay so
under that you will get precision recall if one score support higher satosa precision
means true positive divided by true positive plus false positive recalls means true positive
divided by true positive plus false negative you can also calculate if one score the formula
is 2 into recall into precision divided by precision plus recall and support means the
number of the test samples which are participating here.
So for example if you if you see iris satosa we already have seen 18 from the confusion
matrix right in the first row it was 18 second row it is 11 plus 12 so that is why the support
is 12 or for example if we see in the third row it is 15 participating sample 15 for
the Virginia that is why it is 15 here okay and you can see they are corresponding values
in terms of the precision recall if one score you can also calculate the accuracy as well
okay so also the macro average and micro average so if you sum them up okay 1 plus 1 plus 0.94
divided by 3 it will be 0.98 so macro average is nothing but the average column wise average
if it is precision at these 3 values divided by 3 simple average calculation similar for
the recall F1 score you will get this macro average values which is present here and similarly
for the weighted average you can do the same thing weighted average what will happen individual
precision into the corresponding support value divided by total support okay.
So you will do the sum and then you will basically again in the next case individual precision
value into support value plus again individual precision value like Iris Virginia 0.94 into
support divided by total yes okay so total weight 45 so it will give you the weighted
average okay.
So for your assistant purpose I already have mentioned the explanations here okay so if
you see precision 2 positive divided by 2 positive plus false positive recall 2 positive divided
by 2 positive plus false negative F1 score like I mentioned 2 into precision into recall
divided by precision plus recall okay they are the standard mathematical formula 2 positive
what is 2 positive from your commonsense you can understand it if model correctly predicts
the positive class 2 positive model correctly similarly model correctly predicts the negative
class then it will be 2 negative if the model what will be the false positive if the model
incorrectly predicts the positive plus it will be false positive if the model incorrectly
predicts the negative plus it will be false negative.
So in short for the 2 positive it is tp for 2 negative it is tn for the false positive
it is fp for the false negative it is fn and like I mentioned that support means the number
of the times the test samples which are appearing okay so that is the support okay macro average
I already told you simple calculate all the values for the precision and then average
then if it is the 3 value then add them and divide by 3 if it is 4 value then you add
those 4 values divide by 4 like the way we calculate the average okay and weighted average
it will be similarly the individual class precision into the individual class support
okay you take the sum of them and divide by total support similarly if it is recall then
what will happen individual class recall into individual class support take the sum of them
and divide by total support so in this way you will calculate the weighted average okay
so all those calculations have been given there and for the accuracy it is 2 positive
plus 2 negative divided by 2 positive plus 2 negative plus false positive plus false
negative okay so in this way you basically do the entire operations so mathematical formulas
I have added there so for example in case you want to test them manually you can do it
and try it you will get this type of the results which has been shown in the original notebook
okay so please finish this up so result 1 how the classification report has been calculated
how the accuracy score calculated and stood under result 2 I have mentioned okay so please
finish this up and let me know okay so remember accuracy score here we calculated over y test
and y print and we have printed the result and we got it 0.977 something that means approximately
97.78% so remember in test in training data set we got 95. something 95.24 and the test
data set we got 97.78% that means even we are getting the better result than the training
data set okay so that means that you do not there is no scenarios like overfitting okay
so it is absolutely doing well our net base classifier is absolutely performing well okay
and the result is trust of the okay so before going to support vector machine please finish
this small chunk of the code and let us complete a net base and move towards the support vector
machine portion so all of you now know what you have to do you simply click on the plus
code button back to put it there and execute this step okay and you see this is the result
so I am not re-explaining again I already told you twice or thrice what are the meaning
of all those outcomes okay so just finish this up before we can proceed to the next
part which is support vector machine so it is 10, 10, 10pm and then we shall move ahead
so by 10, 12 we will finish it and then we shall start the support vector machine portion.
so I shall wait for few more seconds before we can move to the next step so please
finish this up
okay so let us move to the next portion that is support vector machine so in support vector
machine basically we will see the explorations of the different kernels so already you are
aware of the linear polynomial RBF sigmoid type of the kernel so in the linear kernel
is very much good for exploring the linearly separable values but for the non-linearly separable
cases RBF and the RBF or Gaussian and sigmoid kernel are better okay these kernels are
computationally very much smart to separate the non-linearly separable values so all of
you know what is kernel already in last class Dr. Vikant Chakraborty has mentioned that
how to separate the non-linearly separable values in higher dimension taking them to
the higher dimensions and in those cases RBF sigmoid kernel those who played the important
role okay so RBF kernel is nothing but the Gaussian kernel which can separate the non-linearly
separable values smartly whereas sigmoid kernel is basically act as a like the sigmoid activation
function which actually can separate the non-linearly separable values okay okay so these are the
few important concept which you already have learned it so here we will just deploy those
concepts in exploring in the this type of the python or pythonic platforms okay so basically
from sklearn.svm you can import the support vector classifier svc and then you are creating
an empty list accuracy underscore list under the square bracket and then for i in we are
basically we will explore one by one kernel okay so we are basically putting within the
list a linear poly which stands for the polynomial kernel which is also a very effective kernel
like the linear RBF and sigmoid kernel okay then RBF and then sigmoid okay and we are keeping
them under the each item will be under the single coded okay and then we will basically
assign svc classifier and store it under clf so kernel equals to i so it will keep on accessing
one by one kernel sequentially and will print the result then y-print equals to wide sorry
clf.fit it will be applied over the extrane of y-print and then y-print equals to clf.predict
we will apply it over the extrane and then we will calculate the accuracy score like
we did earlier okay so first we will do it for the training data set as I told you because
knowing the effectiveness of the algorithm over training is very important so that while
executing the test data set you can easily learn that how it is performing whether any
overfitting is happening or not that you will be able to learn okay then what will happen
that you will apply it over the extrane and y-print you will apply accuracy function over
them and store it under accuracy and simply then accuracy underscore list dot append accuracy
will deploy and then you will print it like the way I told you because the way you want
to show the output it will be printed so like for example we are keeping the string under
accuracy of then plus i so under i those values are present linear poly RBF sigma so sequentially
if you see the output it is showing accuracy of in this case as i is present plus i that
means it will be linear here in the second line it will be poly in the third line it
will be RBF I am showing you the output how it is coming out and fourth line this sigmoid
then again you see we have given the E string okay and then float accuracy so it will the
floating point value which is coming up for example in linear 0.96 upper is 0.9619 something
or for example here 0.8857 something or for example in this case third row if you check
0.971428 something or in the fourth row 0.8952 something so in this way the accuracy will
be printed for all those kernel like it is whether it can be linear polynomial RBF or
sigmoid okay so in this way you can do it okay so let us explore this one and then after
testing the efficacy of the algorithm over the training dataset we shall move them move
ahead for the testing them in test dataset okay so let us first complete the step so
all of you know we have to click on the plus code and then we can put it right here and
then run okay so it has run smoothly and you can check the corresponding accuracy for the
linear polynomial RBF as the sigmoid kernel performance okay so it is now 1016 please finish
this step by 1018 you may get different values or you may get the same values for certain
kernels but you have to check that which one is giving you the better result and depending
on the different datasets and the alignment of the data points certain kernels will give
you the better result in certain cases okay
so I repeat linear kernel helps you to separate the linearly separable values in an effective
way polynomial kernel helps you to do the complex polynomial modeling okay so that
you can get the optimum result through the explore through by exploring this polynomial
function I told you that RBF kernel or Gaussian kernel is very much effective for computing
the non-linearly separable values okay for by classifying this non-linearly separable
values sigmoid is another effective function kernel function of classifying non-linearly
separable values under support vector machine okay.
So please finish this step I shall wait for another more minute and then move to the next
part so please finish this up.
So let us move to the next part so under accuracy let us put because we want to plot them okay
so we want to generate a comparison plot like this so because of that as a initiation of
the step we are what we are doing we are assigning the index value under the accuracy list.
So accuracy list basically it is a dictionary format okay key value pairs okay this is called
the key value pairs I think Suman bear has mentioned during the Python session so accuracy
equals to linear accuracy list so this is a zero that means linear activation function
value will be stored under it then polynomial accuracy underscore least one so it will be
polynomial kernel value will be stored under it then RBF okay so accuracy underscore least
two that means RBF kernel will be stored under it then sigmoid as a Python is a zero indexing
language so if there are four values so index value will line from 0 1 2 3 so in this way
this dictionary format is forming the key value pairs and we are storing it under accuracy
list okay so then what you will do you have to generate PLT dot figure okay figure size
we are giving for example standard 8 by 6 okay and then we SNS dot bar plot okay X list
accuracy keys and Y equals to list accuracy values as we have formed the key value pairs
KB pairs okay because of that we had defining them in the SNS dot bar plot then we are keeping
X level under the kernel these are the kernel values because linear polynomial RBF sigmoid
the way we have defined in this sequence it will be printed and then Y level it will be
the accuracy as you can see the accuracy calculations has been given there because all the values
is more than basically 80 percent lowest one is 88 percent as we can see as per my original
notebook it is 88.57 right so better to keep the values between 0.80 to 100 0.80 to 1
that means 80 percent to 100 if it is 80 percent to 100 if you want to keep the Y axis limits
then to show the difference better in a better way so we will keep 0.80 to 1 so that is why
we have given the Y axis it 0.80 to 1 okay you can clearly see the differences between
these bar plots in that case so that is why Y limit has been set up there in this way
and PLT dot show you will get the following plots and the title as we need accuracy of
different SVM kernels on Irish dataset okay so I believe that all of you got the purpose
of assigning the X level Y level title even the limit of the Y limit okay so let us do
one by one so first assign the key value pairs under accuracy with this dictionary format
of the python or pythonic file and then we shall move ahead for the next step generating
the comparative bar plots for the different kernel performances so you see this portion
has been executed successfully then now we shall go ahead for executing this one generating
the plots comparable plots here so you see this is the comparative plots here for example
why it is three values are same because already you got see interestingly linear polynomial
RBF kernel is giving you 97.14 percent okay these three values are same but you get sigmoid
it is 89.52 percent so that is why the value has dropped here okay so first finish these
two steps and then we shall go ahead so these two first execute this particular run cell
I mean this particular cell with by clicking on the run cell button and then you execute
this particular plots okay so it is now 1022 please finish this step by 1024 couple of
minutes more will be good enough to execute this one and then we shall move ahead for
the next portion of discussions.
So, we shall move ahead for the next section of discussion.
So, I shall wait for few more seconds so please finish this up then we shall move ahead.
Okay., so we shall move ahead for the next section of discussion.
So, we shall move ahead for the next section of discussion.
Okay, so let us move to the next portion now so already we have seen and as you can see
I have jotted down the explanation of the result so in this way we have achieved the
highest accuracy with the RBF kernel in this case for example in this notebook we got the
highest accuracy of the RBF kernel as simple as that if you look at the diagram original
notebook I am talking about so it is 97.14 percent in the linear kernel we have achieved
the second highest accuracy it is 96.19 percent okay third one we have got for the sigmoid
kernel that is 89.52 percent and the lowest one is 88.57 percent respectively and which
we got for the polynomial card okay so all these accuracies over the training dataset
is very good now we have to check it for the test dataset okay so similar way what we will
do we will we will create the empty list accuracy list then for I will keep one by one kalenek
linear polynomial RBF sigmoid all those kernels we will put up there and then CLF equals to
SVC support vector classifier kernel equals to I and then what we will do we will apply
the CLF dot feed function over the X train and Y train and then Y pred equals to CLF
dot predict we will apply that particular function over X test and then we will calculate the
accuracy score we will apply the accuracy score function over Y test and Y pred and
then accuracy underscore list dot append over accuracy we will apply it and then we will
print the result one by one like the way same which we have done or the similar which we
have done earlier so I am not re explaining the steps again so this is you can see this
is the analog step only we are doing it over the test dataset earlier what we have done
it over the training dataset okay so the steps are same I am not repeating it again here
we have got if you see the accuracy values okay over the test dataset during applying
them okay the accuracy of the linear kernel 0.9777 polynomial as well as the RBF kernel
same value that means 97.78 percent for the sigma we have got 93.33 percent okay so this
particular portion you just first finish it up over the test dataset and then we will
try to generate the plot here and then they are going to okay so this is the these are
the values now one question often comes up in your mind those who are new to it that
why the values are varying okay during the time of the execution because you see during
the test and training and test split okay the samples are not same which you are taking
earlier okay it may vary so for example what may happen that 0 to 104 index value can go
for the training and 0105 to 149th for the testing purpose because 70 percent of the
samples okay and this is for example 105 70 percent of 150 values means it will be 105
simple as that 30 percent of 150 is your equal equals to 45 so during the trend test split
this can be the one of the splitting so for this split you will get one result if if you
get the for example if you get some some sort of this kind of the combinations like for
example 45 to 149 for the training
and this combination is for testing because randomly if these things are happening then
automatically because of this different participating samples your output will vary right for the
different combinations you are getting different type of the result because random selections
of during the trend test split is happening differently that is why for the name base
or during the SVM or for the KNN you will get the different result trend test split
so these two examples of the trend test split I have given to you okay for the different
combo okay so I hope the picture is clear to all of you now fine okay so please finish
this step this is 1031 so finish this step by 1032 then we shall move to the next step
of generating this type of the plots okay.
Well I believe all of you have been able to finish this now a similar step I am not re-explaining
again for generating this type of the bar diagram okay so as you can see in my result
in original notebook as these three values are same linear poly and RBF so with the same
logic of generating the plot we got this three values same as per the bar diagram sigma value
was the lower one so that is why we got this 93. something percentage okay so let us first
explore this one this accuracy portion in the demo window notebook and then generating
the bar diagram by differing the fixed size X level Y level and the title of the plot along
with the Y limit so here we see this type of the plots we are getting in the demo window
because we got the different result okay like for example in linear kernel we got the linear
and RBF kernel in demo window we got the highest accuracy 97.78 percent approximately so these
two bar diagrams are giving us the highest result for the linear and RBF whether as for
the polynomial we got 0.88 something and the sigmoid is the lowest 1.86 something so that
is why it is 88.88 percent approximately for polynomial and 86.66 percent for the sigmoid
this one the lowest one okay so in your case accordingly the way we will learn you will
get the way we are getting the output similarly we will get the bar diagram okay.
So it is 1033 so finish this two step by 1035 okay so that we can move ahead after seeing
the accuracy of different SVM kernels on iris data set test data set.
So whatever the result you have got you actually have seen that result are not much deviating
if we see individual kernel wise in comparison to the data result you got in the training
data set okay either same or nearby it sometimes better sometime lower okay.
So from this we can easily conclude one thing that we are not over fitting or the algorithm
is not over fitting okay whatever the result we are getting it is fine it is acceptable
as the training data set and test data results are closer to each other okay or the same
that means it is acceptable performance okay.
So, let us see how we can do this.
Okay, so I believe we can move to the next step now all of you have been able to complete
it okay.
So what we will do we will generate now this type of the conclusion matrix thank you okay.
So for this conclusion matrix already we have learned how to do it for example sklearn.metrics
import classification report conclusion matrix accuracy score and then we shall apply the
conclusion matrix over the Y test and Y freedom we are storing at the result and the basically
the result section and then sns.heatmap the first argument will be the result, second
argument will be the annotation true.
So that is why the participating samples are appearing in each grid of the conclusion
matrix and then fmt equals to g which is the general format okay.
So basically the left hand side of the decimal value the entire integer value which will
appear like 18, 0 or 9 because this is the general format we are using then x t level
y t level for the setosa versicolor virginica setosa versicolor virginica will be there
x level actual y level prediction font size we are keeping 13, conclusion matrix the title
which is the highest font size we are giving 17, we will show you the following result.
So as per the result you can see the similar we have defined during nape base that 18 setosa
samples has been correctly classified as setosa out of 12, 9 has been correctly classified
as versicolor 3 wrongly as virginica, 15 out of 15 correctly classified as virginica okay.
So this is how the interpretation has been added for your assistant purpose you see I
have added the interpretation here so things are clearly visible to all of you.
So please finish this part before we can move to the KNN classifier okay.
So generate the conclusion matrix and see the results.
So in our case in demo window we are getting this 11 setosa out of 11 correctly classified
as setosa out of 12 correctly classified as versicolor 5 wrongly as virginica, out of
17 16 has been correctly classified as virginica and 1 wrongly as versicolor.
So in this way you can generate the interpretation okay whatever the results you are getting
because I already have shown you why that during the test train test split the participant
testing samples are varying between the training and testing cases during the use.
So because of that reason okay your overall result is actually varying it is keeping the
impact over the results okay.
So generate the outcome and let us go to the KNN execution.
So it is now 1038 please finish this step by 1040 so that we can move towards the implementation
of the KNN classifier which is the last portion of our class okay hands on class actually
there will be a theory session after that but for the hands on part we will execute
.
, I shall wait for few more seconds before we can move to the next step those who have
already read find those who are doing it please finish it.
Thank you.
Well so let us move to the next part KNN classifier.
So in KNN KNRS neighborhood already we have learnt the concept of the KNRS neighborhood.
So here what we will do before as a part of the hands on session.
So we will take from escalant.neighbors we will import the KN neighbors classifier and
KN neighbors classifier will take the 8 neighborhood points to classify the correct sample okay.
So now KN neighbors classifier AN_neighbors will keep as 8 and we store it under classifier
and then we will execute the classifier.fit over the X train and Y train okay.
So this is the very basic steps which we will do before calculating the accuracy over the
KNN for the KNN classifier for different KN values.
Our objective will be to get the highest accuracy and figure out for which K value we are getting
it okay.
Or there can be multiple K values which we may get for the highest accuracy that means
that will be the lowest error point okay.
So that means we should have to first execute the basics setup for let us start with the
KN neighbor classifier for KN neighbor values of the 8 okay.
First to avoid any kind of the overfitting scenario or the underfitting scenario for
example if we take the K equals to 1, K equals to 2 or 3 that can be two simple, simplistic
cases and that may create the underfitting cases.
So that is why we are avoiding it.
We are starting from I advise you to start from the 6, 7 or 8 values like this value to
try out figure out for which K value you are getting the highest accuracy.
So here we are starting with the neighbor K neighbor values as the N neighbor values
as 8 okay and we will see how it performs.
So it is now 1042.
So please finish this step by 1043 there are basic three lines of the codes okay.
So just finish it then we shall move to the next step.
So in the next step we will implement the classifier.predict over X train okay and we
will calculate it okay.
So we will apply accuracy underscore values over Y train and Y parade and then we will
calculate the accuracy values.
So like I told you thus to compare and avoid the overfitting scenarios and compare the
performances of the algorithm over training and test data is very important.
So that is why we shall explore this one for the training dataset for N neighbors equals
to 8 okay and we will see that in which K value we are getting the optimum result.
Let us move to the next step so like I told you now we are going to check for K equals
to 8 what we will get the accuracy.
So in the demo window we are getting the accuracy it is 95.238 that means 95.24 percent okay
and whereas my original window original notebook it is 96.19 percent okay that means 0.9619
96.19 percent okay this we are getting for the 8 neighbor value 8 okay.
So it is now 1044 please finish this step to generate the accuracy for the first case
by 1045 then we shall check out for the N neighbors value 9 what we are getting.
So I repeat this particular value 8 is actually defining the particular class for a new point
data point in terms of the majority of the voting for which class it belongs to okay.
So for example in first case we got the accuracy as per my demo into it is 95.24 percent approximately
and original window it has 96. Something so it is a very good result but we are trying
to figure out for which K value or more than one there can be multiple K values actually
we are getting the highest result we are trying to tap that particular point okay.
So now let us see so it is already 1045 so I believe that you have been able to incorporate
this particular portion. So let us move to the next value that is 9 let us try out with
9 okay. So steps will be same only what you will do you will replace the N neighbors value
will update the N neighbors value okay. So that is why I am not again re-explaining the
steps we will only update the N neighbors value and keep on testing that for which case
we are getting the highest result okay.
So first execute this one and then go for executing the classification accuracy portion
as we are doing it over the training dataset so there will be no change here also okay.
So in here for K equals 9 I got the same earlier it is 0.9619 that means 96.19 percent K equals
to 8 and K equals 9 you also got the same accuracy okay. So let us see in my demo into
what I am achieving in your case also keep on watching that in which K value got the
highest accuracy here I can see in my case it is dropping 9.9485 it might happen that
at K equals to 8 I got already got the highest accuracy as it is dropping. Let me cross check
with one or two values more whether I get the better result or not in your case you
see whether the result is same whether you are getting the better result or whether it
is dropping okay. Just for the confirmation purpose if it is dropping check out another
one or two point okay then you conclude that in which point you got the result highest
result okay.
So repeat that N neighbors value taking 1, 2, 3 this type of the values will make the
model too simple and too biased so that will be under footing scenario it will be a bias
model. So because of that it is better to start from 6, 7 or 8 that kind of the values.
So with certain efforts you will be able to figure out the highest accuracy maybe at K
equals to 11, 12 or 10 or even 8 okay fine.
So it is now 1047 so finish this step by 1048 this two step for N neighbors 9 there is no
change in the code remember from now onwards what we will do we will only replace the value
of the N neighbors that is it okay and make some try to make some conclusion then we will
move the same repeat the same steps for the stage dataset and make some conclusions which
one is the better okay.
So let me go back to the original notebook and try out to the next value that is the
N neighbors 10 okay. So those who are doing it I hope all of you got the steps so I do
not need to wait for you because already you have understood only you have to change the
N neighbor values and with the execution of these subsequent two cells you can easily
deal with the calculation of the accuracies.
So here we are doing it for the N neighbors 10 okay and similar way only you can see only
the N neighbor value has been updated and now we are trying to figure out for the accuracy
calculation same code okay. For example in my case in original window I got the same accuracy
even at K equals to 10 okay. It may be possible that this is forming a play to where the all
highest accuracies are lying with certain K values 8, 9, 10 okay you never know.
So that is why you need to keep on testing here let me check this one will be the interesting
my demo window result will be the interesting okay. Let me check whether it is dropping
or is there any increase no it has dropped 94.9485. So already I got the highest accuracy
at K equals to 8 with my first attempt in 19 it is again dropping okay. So here I can
conclude that at K equals to 8 neighborhood point is giving us the better result okay
best result that is 95.23 okay. So for you you keep on trying to figure out for example
those who got the 10 you can again replace the value for 11. If you already got the highest
accuracy value and seeing the drop like me which I observe in the demo window you must
keep it and those who are seeing the same accuracy like my original window or seeing
any improvement they try to figure out the point in which point it is dropping. So if
it is dropping at K equals to 13 then you can say that at K equals to 12 or 10 to 12
you are getting the highest accuracy.
You are getting the highest accuracy like for example at 11 okay if you can check my accuracy
is dropping here. That means I got the highest result that is why I have concluded here here
we have observed that the KNN algorithm is doing well for the values K equals to 8, 9,
10 and 11 where it has achieved the highest accuracy for 96.19% at K equals to 8, 9, 10
on the training dataset. We have tried out for the different values of K, 8, 9, 10 and
11 where it has achieved the highest accuracy of 96.19% at K equals to 8, 9, 10 on the training
dataset because at 11 we have seen the drop of the accuracy.
So that is why we concluded that our highest accuracy range is 8, 9, 10. Like I told you
may get the single point you may get the multiple point while predicting the accuracy for a
new data point depending on the other neighborhood points. So how you got the concept. So this
is what the training dataset result okay. Now we can do it for the testing data. Let
us see training result we got 96.1 and which is a very good result. Now we have to see
that for what will happen for the test scenario. So like a form of standard practice we shall
apply classifier.predict function over X test and we will store it under Y print okay. Let
us go back to the demo window and try it out for the test samples done.
And then from a scalar dot metric we shall import the classification report okay. Confusion
matrix accuracy score and the result will be stored under by applying the confusion
matrix over Y test and Y print and it will be stored under result variable okay. So let
us do it. So please complete these two steps it is now 1052 please complete these two steps
by 1054 okay. Now we are at the end of our session where we are basically exploring the
KNN algorithm over the test samples. Already we have seen during the training sample we
got for 8, 9, 10 from as per my demo window original window we got the highest accuracy
96.19 and as per my demo window I got 95. something at k equals to 8 which is the highest okay.
In your case I hope you have noted down that in which particular case you got the highest
result okay. And similar way I am telling you because of today morning we have started
with Naive base we explore SVM for different kernels now you are doing KNN as we are doing
it over the same data set okay. Please add also training stage sample training stage
sample split also the same 70 percent 30 percent what you have done in terms of the quantity.
So make a comparative table for your learning purpose okay. So that you can get some idea
that for which algorithm you are getting the better result for your case okay. It will
be a good learning because you can compare whenever you are doing some project it will
help you to compare the performances of the different algorithms.
In the next class for example during this supervised learning 2 hands on session we
shall have another more experiences over the d addition exploring trees random forest you
can that will be done on the same data set. So you can compare them at the end of the
day for supervised learning which one is giving you the best result okay. So it is now 1053
I believe all of you have been able to finish this part. So now we will generate the hit
map this type of the with sns.itmap we shall generate this type of the confusion matrix
okay. So as the all of you already got the idea since morning I am explaining this step
so I am not repeating it again. So just check that in your case what type of the confusion
matrix you are getting. So as per my original notebook you see 18 setosa has been correctly
classified as setosa 12 versicolor has been correctly classified as versicolor and 15
virginica has been correctly classified as virginica so you got the 100% accuracy okay.
All the case you are getting the correct results like 80 out of 18 has been correctly classified
as setosa out of 12 versicolor 12 has been correctly classified as versicolor out of 15
virginica has been correctly classified as virginica. So you see the explanation also
added there okay and I will also calculate the accuracy here also okay.
So if we see the similar type of the results whether we have got the same result or different
let us see in the demo notebook. In the demo notebook as we can see 11 has been out of
11 setosa has been correctly classified as setosa out of 17 17 has been correctly classified
as versicolor out of 17 15 has been correctly classified as virginica too wrongly as versicolor.
This is what we have observed in the demo window there are few wrong classifications okay.
So all as this is the same code I am not waiting for you you can do it now because you already
have this one is the same thing for generating the confusion matrix now what we will do this
portion is also you have with you because this is same code for generating the classification
report as well as the accuracy. As per the confusion matrix you do not have to explain
that the accuracy will be 100 percent because there is no wrong classification okay.
So as you can see this is the highest accuracy which we have achieved for K equals to 9 the
case data set K equals to 9 sorry because I am talking about it is 100 percent now we
will see that is for the let us we will check out for the K equals to 9 what we will achieve.
So this particular portion of the code let me run for the demo window okay for the demo
window let me let me put it there and let us check.
So in the demo window it is 95.56 percent because in the last row you see there were
two wrong classifications right out of 1715 has been kindly classified as virginica and
too wrongly as versicolor in your in our case original notebook it is 100 percent now we
shall go and test the accuracy for the K equals to 9 okay.
So that we will explore here so this particular portion already we have the code with you okay.
So we will put just replace in neighbors equals to 9 okay and check it out then we will what
we will do we will do the classifier dot predict we shall apply over the X test okay and then
we will generate the confusion matrix okay.
So these steps let us do it in my demo window you also explore it for you for the test result.
So once you do it then you go for the classifier dot predict we apply it over the X test
and then what will be the next step next step we will be calculating the confusion matrix
okay and you will store it under the result just to check whether you are getting the
better result or not and then you generate the confusion matrix in my case it is again
same even at K equals to 9 I am getting the accuracy 100 percent okay.
So there is no point of checking more because already I am at the highest point so I can
conclude that K equals to 9 is my optimum point for the test result okay and it is not
debating much because in the as per the original notebook I got the highest accuracy in case
of KNN it was something like if I check from my original notebook I got the highest accuracy
for K equals to 8, 9, 10 that is basically your 96.19 percent okay and from the test
data set I am getting even better result 100 percent okay at K equals to 9.
So there is no point of checking because it is already I got the highest point there might
be some multiple values or single point value I am getting it okay that for verifying that
you can check it out further okay but I think in demo window let me try out because there
are some errors okay for the demo window cases it will be interesting scenario to check whether
I am getting the better result or not okay so those who have drawn the confusion matrix
check it out again by doing it out for classification report and accuracy score whether you are
getting the better result or not or for which point you are getting the best result that
you may check out.
For here I can see again 95.55 for K equals to 9 and the K equals to 8 both the cases
I am getting the same result for the test data set 95.56 okay so let me check that whether
it is dropping or not for another point like K equals to 10 in that case let me figure
out okay.
So for example I can try it out for the K equals to 10 and again check okay like in
my notebook okay I got I am getting the 100 percent accuracy but in demo notebook I can
see some errors.
So that is why it will be much more we have to be much more watchful that for which point
I am getting the better accuracy so I am trying it for the K equals to 10 okay.
So for example only the values will be changed rest of the code will remain same okay just
you have to follow the sequence of the execution okay so confusion matrix portion is done.
Now let us generate the heat map in the demo window okay so here you can see it will again
the same scenario 11 out of 11 has been correctly classified as 17 has been correctly classified
as Virginia out of 17 15 has been correctly classified as Virginia and 2 wrongly as versi
color okay.
So now let me just generate the classification report it will be same I mean 95.56.
So what I can do I can skip the value already we have seen that 8 9 10 95.56 percent okay
the demo window as per the demo window 8 9 10 all these three values in demo window we
got the 95.56 percent okay.
So continuously I am getting it so we have to figure out that whether this is the highest
accuracy or whether it is dropping okay so for that what we can do we can simply just
change the value I am just skipping going to the 13 or 14 for example I am taking n
neighbors equals to 13 in my demo window because original notebook I got 100 percent
at 8 9 10 so I am not again checking it because that is already we got the highest accuracy
okay because over 100 percent nothing is possible it will drop at certain point okay.
So no point of checking it so we can conclude that we are getting the highest accuracy at
8 9 10 and there is no over fitting okay 96 point something over the training data set
and for the test data set 100 for the demo window I am checking it those who are getting
the same result like my demo window okay.
So they can figure it out because 8 9 10 we got the same result.
So I want to check that in which point it is dropping okay.
So like if I keep n neighbors equals to 14 let me check that is there any changes whether
we are observing any changes or not.
Okay so in conclusion matrix it is changing 11 out of 11 setosa has been correctly classified
17 out of 17 varsity color has been correctly classified out of 17 14 Virginia has been correctly
classified 3 Romley has been classified as varsity color okay.
Now we can see the changes okay let us generate the classification report here.
So here you can see the drop in accuracy.
So already we got the peak at K equals to 8 9 10 but here in 13 we can see the drop in
accuracy that is 93.33 percent in the demo window okay.
So in this way you can check it out okay in which point you are getting the highest accuracy
and for example if at K equals to 10 you are getting the highest accuracy at 11 you may
check the check out it is dropping okay.
So you have to figure out that particular case that whether a single point of the K value
or the multiple point of the K value you may get the highest accuracy okay.
But after certain point of time you may see the drop okay so you have to figure out that
particular point to get the confirmation of your highest accuracy value for a certain
K value okay.
And like I mentioned that do not make your model too simplistic to avoid any biasness
in the result.
So that is why K it is always better to avoid the lower values of the K like 2 or 3 better
to check it out from 6 7 that type of the things okay.
To avoid the biasness or the under floating scenarios in your system okay and also compare
your result over the test data set what you are achieving in case of the training data
set just to make confirmation that whether any overfitting is happening or not.
So today we have completed the demonstrations handguns demonstration on all of you have
successfully done it with me for the SVM support vector machine along with different kernel
comparisons and we have considered the kernels like linear, polynomial, RBF kernel as well
as the sigmoid kernel.
We also have explored the handguns session over nape base and finally we have done it
for the KNN algorithm.
So Dr. Ovegan Chakraborty will start the session on the support vector machine part 2 here
you will see the exploration over the decision trees at random forest.
So let me ask professor so I am concluding it here so there should be a break of 5 minutes.
So if you have any queries I am joining the moderation section so I will reply there okay.
So I am not answering it live because already professor has arrived so I am replying them
in the offline mode during my moderation duty okay.
So thank you very much for joining my session there is a break of 5 minutes I am thankful
to all the back end support from the support staff of this smart class room.
Subradhoda great job by Devjit and let us start the session of Dr. Ovegan Chakraborty
for supervised learning part 2 it will start within 5 minutes so please put the 5 minute
break there.
Thank you very much for joining my session thank you sir.